pietro wilson tossed and turned as the
nightmares from the previous day
filled his dreams in his restless sleep
he watched the slaughter of his
colleagues at site-22
the unknown men who entered the facility
had gunned down everyone who worked
there
everyone except pietro he remembered
running deeper into the facility
only to be cornered in a windowless
concrete room there he had found
scp-5000 an exclusionary suit that
allowed him to become
undetectable to human senses it was a
step beyond invisibility
he successfully made it out of sight 22
but the eyes of the men he killed to get
away
haunted him pietro had never taken a
life before
the only solace was that it felt like
the suit he was wearing had taken over
so his actions were not technically his
own
but he had to wonder what would he have
done without the suit
would he still have killed another human
to escape after leaving the facility
pietro had made his way to an scp safe
house this was where he now lay
the slaughter of hundreds at site-22 was
bad but what he found when he turned on
the news at the safe house
was worse scps had been let loose around
the world
and were killing people by the millions
what was going on
pietro was startled awake from a
nightmare he was hyperventilating but
his body almost
immediately recovered and his breathing
slowed a heads-up display flashed on in
front of his eyes
pietro wilson was still contained with
an scp-5000
the suit would not let him go he
instinctively went to rub his eyes
but the metal hands of the suit just
clanked against the helmet that covered
his head
he wanted out of this suit pietro stood
up and walked over to the television
he reached out to turn it on but paused
he thought
do i really want to see how bad things
have gotten since i fell asleep
but he had to know he was filled with
dread as the tv came on and he saw the
first images
the world looked as if it was ending and
it seemed like the scp
foundation was responsible how could
this be
they were supposed to protect humanity
not destroy it
pietro needed to uncover the truth
behind what was happening
scp-5000 had a log entry function that
he could use to record everything he
uncovered
even if he didn't make it out of this
live maybe one day
someone would find the suit and be able
to access what he had learned
the date of his first journal entry was
february 1st 2020
as pietro watched the carnage unfold on
tv he began to put together the pieces
of what he had witnessed himself
he knew a special ops squad had executed
everyone at site-22 where he worked
he knew that the scps had been let loose
he knew the world was ending
but why has pietro pondered this a
newscaster appeared
what you have just witnessed are reports
from around the world of monsters
ravaging cities and towns
this all started with a mysterious
message from an organization that calls
itself the scp foundation
their ruling body named the o5 council
released the following statement
for those who are not currently aware of
our existence we represent the
organization known
as the scp foundation our previous
mission centered around the containment
and study of anomalous objects
entities and other assorted phenomena
this mission was the focus of our
organization for more than 100 years
due to circumstances outside of our
control this directive has now
changed our new mission will be the
extermination
of the human race there will be no
further communication
he couldn't believe what he was seeing
the scp foundation had declared war on
the human race
how could this be what had led to the o5
council changing their entire mission
from protecting humanity to ending it
could it be possible that a powerful scp
had taken control
or influenced the council's decision
pietro turned on the radio
flipped through tv channels and scoured
the internet for information on what had
happened over the past 24 hours the
first image he saw was a human-like
creature with arms and legs twice as
long as they should have been
with deep black eyes and a mouth curled
up into a silent screen
showing teeth as sharp as razor blades
from the files he could access
pietro learned that this was scp-096
a creature that was docile until someone
saw its face
at which point the scp would start to
shriek and cry before hunting down
whoever saw its face and slaughtering
them
he quickly changed the channel the file
said that even if scp-096 was seen on a
screen
it would find the viewer and tear them
limb from limb surely that couldn't be
true
there were potentially millions of
people who had just seen it on tv
what would happen to them what would
happen to him
on the next channel was footage of a
gigantic animal in the middle of the
ocean
this was scp-169 a leviathan from the
pre-cambrian era
the creature was around 000 kilometers
long and slowly swam
just below the surface of the ocean the
feed suddenly changed to footage of
devastating tsunamis and destruction
caused by earthquakes
when scp-169 had been awoken from its
slumber by the foundation
detonating nukes on its back it began
trying to escape the danger
the movement of the massive creature
caused natural disasters
destroying coastal communities around
the world
on another channel pietro was watching
as the chancellor of germany gave a
speech announcing that the country was
declaring war on the scp foundation
off-camera the sound of a tinkling bell
could be heard a man dressed as a
victorian-era butler
entered and picked up a pen from the
chancellor's desk
he approached the chancellor and raised
the pen in the air as the camera cut
away
but the sound of gunshots and yelling
could be heard before the feed went dead
the news reported that similar events
involving world leaders by the exact
same butler had been occurring since the
scp foundation changed its mission
pietro searched through the suit's files
to try and figure out what was happening
and found that scp-662 must have been
connected
next was a strange skin disease plaguing
new york and delhi designated scp-610
that covered its hosts in rashes and
boils before seeking to take over their
bodies
finally some good news though as the
outbreak looked to be contained by the
combined efforts of the global occult
coalition and the church of the broken
god
and then some bad news as scp-682 had
also been released a massive crocodilian
monster
its sole mission was to destroy all life
it was fueled by hatred for living
things making it the perfect tool of the
o5 council's new
stated mission pietro had heard rumors
of scps that could instantly end the
world
but clearly the foundation hadn't gone
down this route
yet did they want to keep the rest of
the planet intact
or maybe there were holdouts in the scp
foundation who were trying to stop the
o5 council from carrying out their
mission
all pietro knew was that right now there
were some real nasty scps running around
wrecking havoc pietro suddenly heard an
explosion in the distance
far away but still close enough to make
him nervous
maybe he was better off staying in the
safe house and waiting out the
apocalypse
the suit was keeping him healthy
nourished and undetectable to foes
any sane person would have remained
there in seclusion and safety
but pietro needed answers he felt it was
his responsibility to log and try to
make sense of
everything the scp foundation was doing
he brought up a map of scp sites in the
area on his display
the closest was site 19. it was time to
venture out into the end of the world
and find some answers but he was about
to be faced with even more
questions on the way to site 19 pietro
came across something strange
a squad of foundation soldiers and a
clearing they were standing at attention
as their commander paced back and forth
up and down the line the soldiers
uniforms had the insignia mtf epsilon 6
embroidered on them
the commander stopped in front of the
first soldier in the line clapped her
hands and informed the soldier she would
be beginning the check now
the commander pulled out a long knife
and plunged it into the soldier's
shoulder
strangely the soldier did not move make
a sound
or react in any way she moved on to the
next soldier and repeated the process
this continued down the line until she
reached the eighth soldier
this time when the commander stabbed the
shoulder of the soldier
he noticeably winced and cried out in
pain the commander shouted
got a live one pietro watches the
soldiers raised their guns and fired at
the one who had cried out
he dropped to the ground the commander
moved on to the last soldier and put the
knife in his shoulder
there was no reaction all right we're
clear yelp the commander
let's move out pietro waited until the
squad was out of sight
and made his way to the corpse lying on
the ground he scavenged weapons and
basic medical supplies
then he buried the body and recorded
what he had seen in scp-5000's log
he had no idea why the soldier was
killed or why the others didn't feel
pain
maybe they weren't human at all maybe it
was a squad of scps that had a human
infiltrate their ranks
none of this makes sense pietro thought
before continuing on
upon reaching site 19 pietro found it in
disarray
and worse practically all of the scps
that were held at the site had breach
containment
he was able to walk into the compound
unnoticed
and deep in the facility he found
scientists and researchers going about
their business
as if they had no idea what was
happening out in the world
they must have been following the orders
of the o5 council
pietro listened in on conversations
about how to create the maximum number
of human
casualties and which scp should be
released next
he felt a deep hatred for the people in
the facility
how could they be so casual about wiping
out humanity
as he observed more of the workers at
site 19 he noticed something strange
everyone's eyes were cold and dead like
there was no humanity left in them
as if something had got to these
scientists and removed the very souls
from their bodies
pietro stealthily stole a senior staff
member's credentials
and found an empty office where he could
access logs from the facility
to try to get a better idea of the
timeline of events that led to the scp
foundation's war on humanity
he logged into the mainframe and brought
up the entries from the end of the
previous year
he found that late in 2019 a project
called numa became of great interest to
the o5 council
from what pietro could tell the project
had something to do with the collective
human consciousness
also called the psycho space apparently
scp researchers had a breakthrough in
mapping out the psycho space
unfortunately many of the files had been
redacted and there was no way for pietro
to access the unredacted version
after numa had been brought to the
attention of the o5 council
a series of orders were sent out to all
senior staff and site directors
but frustratingly these orders had also
been redacted
all he could see was that after the
orders were sent out a wave of
resignations were submitted across the
foundation
suspiciously a wave of suicides had also
occurred at roughly the same time
what was in these orders the o5 council
then sent out a number of files to all
senior staff and site directors with
instructions to disseminate the
materials among those serving under them
after which both the resignations and
deaths immediately
ceased pietro searched everywhere for
what was in those files
but like so much of the scp database
this information had been redacted as
well
what was clear was that the scp
foundation had begun gearing up for the
extermination of humanity the following
year
the entry log for february 1st 2020 read
mobile task forces are dispatched to all
exclusionary sites to execute all
personnel
immediately following the conclusion of
these missions the foundation declares
war on humanity
this was where pietro wilson's journey
had started he slammed his hands down on
the computer monitor in frustration
the suit absorbed all the impact and
crushed the monitor in half
pietro moved to a new non-smash computer
and logged in again
this time he brought up the most current
entries to see what the o5 council was
up to recently
to see if there were some answers in the
present the scp foundation had been busy
while he was making his way to site 19.
they had released scp-1048 in paris
which now led a horde of bears down the
shop elysee
in the distance pietro thought he could
almost make out a massive red teddy bear
walking between the buildings the scp
foundation was also launching
counter-attacks on any organization that
tried to oppose them
they used scp-1290 to hurl projectiles
at the global occult coalition's base
they were also using scp-1440 to
brainwash people and convince them that
they needed to riot
this caused widespread destruction as
people panicked and were trampled to
death
pietro thought it was sad that such a
kind looking old man could cause so much
destruction
he recorded as much as he could before
deciding that it was time to get out of
sight 19.
although scp-5000 still made him
undetectable
he couldn't shake the feeling that the
lifeless eyes of the staff
were beginning to look his way more and
more often
as pietro exited site 19 the sky glowed
orange with the fires of countless
burning buildings
he needed to find more answers he needed
to uncover the reason the scp foundation
was trying to wipe out humanity
he had learned a lot from site 19 and
was sure that if he could just get to
the next site
he would finally be able to figure out
the foundation's motive
and maybe even how to stop them he took
a step forward
but his heads-up display suddenly went
completely dark
the suit constricted tighter around his
body slowing the blood flow to his brain
he couldn't move as his vision got
dimmer and dimmer
and dimmer until he blacked out
pietro woke to find himself halfway
across the country
it had been three months since he had
been at site 19 and he had no
recollection of anything that had
happened
since his body had taken a toll in these
months
he had new scars and a bandage wrapped
around his head
but the scp-5000 suit did not seem to
have a scratch on it
strangest of all though was the
briefcase that pietro had in his hand
and the uncontrollable need to deliver
it to the mysterious
scp-579
bye